foreign
[Applause]
areas where they don't have access to
all of these things so so they do get
you know the two three meals a day but
it's not enough so as you know as
footballers you need to have recovery
you need to be eating the right kinds of
food so when you see the physical
development it's not the same
[Music]
what we try to do is find local coaches
from the community and we provide these
kids free coaching and we also try to
give them education and health
assistance just to facilitate their
development because we feel it's
important that not all of them are going
to become footballers but at least
they'll become better members of society
[Music]
foreign
what happens is because of extreme
poverty in those areas one easy way of
making money is they try to make you
like sell drugs and they give you that
date you know that this is easy money
when you don't have food to eat or your
kid doesn't have food to eat this is
what they're going to resort to so try
to give them enough tools to hopefully
better their light